the false reporting on the veres system  which anybody can submit is then called  Biden Administration data that's being  collected the website just exists it was  there under Trump and it was there it  continues to be there under Joe Biden  and then the false or at least unchecked  reporting of side effects and deaths to  Bears is used to say stuff like what  Tucker just said now I'm not going to  pull it I don't want to encourage anyone  to submit a false report but you can go  and look at the very system and start  the process of submitting a report don't  do it I did it uh up until the point at  which I would have submitted it and I  started typing in David pakman you know  sir David packman died from the vaccine  treated by this doctor you know whatever  you can just submit it anybody can  submit the information and it's being  taken as quote proof by the anti-vaxx to  say that all of these people are dying  they take it as gospel evidence uh  because it's a government website